since elden ring launched back in
february of this year i have been
attempting to understand the story just
like everybody else i felt like i was
ready to make meaningful and stylish
content with a game that i was very much
looking forward to before the game was
released i wasn't sure how the game
would be received by the mainstream
audience i definitely noticed a very
clear effort by the marketing team of
elden ring that i had not seen before
from any prior release by from software
it felt like everyone knew about elden
ring and even players who had not played
a souls game before would be willing to
try this game just from the hype that
had been generating up to the release i
had thousands of hours under my belt
playing the previous titles by from
software and i felt ready to hit the
ground running with eldon ring to maybe
have a head start on understanding the
plotline and sequence of events that
took place leading up to our journey
through the lands between and i felt
like i did that for the most part
although somehow two of my most
successful videos are one with me just
walking around and asking questions for
six minutes and the other one is me
talking about how awesome radon is and
ever since i've been making videos on my
interpretation of the lore in elden ring
in most of these videos i'm extremely
proud of how they turned out as i
thought they were visually interesting
to watch with an emphasis on simplifying
my explanations on the subject so more
people can understand the story i
thought that researching and making
videos on streamlined subjects within
the lore would help me eventually
understand the overall storyline so i
could get better and better at making
these videos however i can say after
hundreds of hours of playing and
researching the ins and outs of almost
everything this game has to offer i am
now more confused than i was halfway
through my first playthrough i don't
feel confident in almost anything i
write in a script because there's likely
something within the game that
contradicts or devalues that subject to
put it simply trying to master the
understanding of the lore is frustrating
and my flame of ambition to make lore
videos on elden ring has been fading
recently but i won't dare go hollow on
you guys i will continue to thoroughly
research and play the game to hopefully
regain that flame once again that's what
you've all subscribed to this channel
for and i appreciate the support more
than you all could understand what i'm
trying to say is that i need to vent
this frustration out into the air so i
can simply just get over it and get back
to making good videos again i know that
i'm not the only one frustrated with the
story of elden ring and i do understand
that from software stories are meant to
be vague however when it came to the
souls series and bloodborne i at least
felt confident in my findings and
understanding of the story as a whole
however when it comes to elden ring i
sometimes feel like i'm personally being
told or shown something not to help with
the betterment of my understanding of
things but just for the sake of
confusing me further and nothing more
maybe this means i'm just not capable of
understanding a complicated story like
with elden ring i most of the time feel
like an unhinged detective functioning
only off of high amounts of caffeine and
i feel like most of the community acts
and feels this way as well creating
random speculations that just don't have
a ton of evidence supporting those
claims which in turn creates mass
confusion amongst the community at large
but with a game of this magnitude with a
massive interest in trying to figure out
all of this stuff by everybody in the
community this is just bound to happen
it's like when the police are trying to
catch an escaped felon for example and
they use the help of the community to
catch this criminal so they announce
that the felon is wearing a blue shirt
jeans and is in a white van then they
just get spammed with calls all over the
place for every white van that is seen
on the highway and every person wearing
a blue shirt and jeans do you see where
i'm going with this it just creates mass
confusion so you have to go digging
through all of that information to maybe
find something that can actually be seen
as logical or helpful and there are
almost endless examples within the game
of what i'm trying to convey here you
could point out any character boss event
quest line item description anything and
it will turn into a rabbit hole of
unhinged discussion on the true meaning
of any and all of those things and
convincing arguments can be made about
one side or the other with any and all
of those things as well there's so much
compelling information within this game
that it's possible to link quite
literally anything in the game with
something else while at the same time
also just not giving enough information
to make concrete theories with those
comparisons and this leads to random
confusion about basic concepts within
the game's lore which just destroys my
confidence with any clue i find when
researching and playing i suppose what
i'm truly afraid of is creating mundane
videos and content for you guys as i
stagnate with my understanding of eldon
ring's lore i don't want to make a video
that is based on an unhinged theory that
the game is almost seemingly designed
for which is just random bunches of
information that may or may not be
logical with the other beams within the
game's lore and i guess a question that
i should be asking myself is that does
it really need to make sense from
software is well aware that their
dedicated fan base is going to go down
every nook and cranny to uncover the
secrets that their game has to offer
it's a huge part of why their games have
had continued longevity over the years
and have developed such a strong fan
base because most people don't
understand the mysteries of the game
because of the extremely vague
storytelling so it's up to the community
to piece everything together to form a
coherent plot line for everyone to try
and understand new discoveries are made
years after release of all of these
games as there seems to be no end to the
secrets that these games offer and
that's exactly what from software once
they want their player base to continue
to try and understand the game which
makes them keep playing the game and
honestly there is nothing wrong with
from software doing that and at the end
of the day i just want to make good
content for you all to enjoy but the
more i play the game the more i've been
struggling to do so and this isn't
because of a lack of content like i've
been explaining there's seemingly
endless amounts of rabbit holes that we
could go down and discuss endless
comparisons of main themes that we could
speculate on and trying to convey those
themes in a meaningful and
understandable way has not only proven
to be difficult but in some ways feels
almost impossible it's like you have to
pick a side when interpreting the lore
or you'll find yourself helplessly
frustrated in confusion like i am
currently i don't like picking sides
when it comes to this i want to read
both sides of the story so i can truly
understand what it's meant to be but
when both sides of the coin are only
trying to disvalue the other through
confusion instead of logic you come out
with only frustration instead of
understanding and like i said earlier
maybe i'm just not capable of truly
understanding the lore in this game the
more i try to understand the more i just
get confused which wasn't the case with
me with any other from software game
i've played while the storytelling was
still vague with enough research the
lore of dark souls and bloodborne and
sakiro could be easily understood elden
ring is clearly the biggest game that
from software has ever developed and
they even got outside help from george
rr martin to assist in the creation of
the base world and its storyline it's
really not clear exactly what he helped
with but it seems like he was only there
in early development and nothing more
it's possible that the developers had to
change some things around throughout
development that just didn't make sense
with what george created for them and
this adds to my point the story of elden
ring feels like it was written by two
different writers that weren't on the
same page whatsoever this is the
constant feeling i have while trying to
understand elden ring but maybe i'm just
not being patient enough with elden ring
most of the time with from software the
storyline isn't truly understood or
expanded on until dlc releases and the
dlc is most of the time the best parts
of the game overall i believe dlc will
only help with my understanding of eldon
ring's lore because usually the dlcs are
more streamlined experiences with an
open world like elden ring it's easy to
get overwhelmed with everything that
you're finding but we are more than
likely going to get a somewhat linear
experience when dlc releases for elden
ring and with a more linear experience
we'll get information in a more linear
fashion so it'll be easier to link
things together in this way that's
pretty much what i'm looking for at this
point in eldon ring's lifespan and again
maybe that's just because i'm too stupid
or it's because we just aren't meant to
understand the storyline yet maybe it's
just because i personally prefer the
more linear aspects of from software's
previous titles and i'm just not used to
this new style of souls game yet i have
to be able to adapt to something new or
i won't be able to truly understand the
world that i'm playing in finally i want
to make clear that my frustration here
is my own fault i still believe that
eldon ring is a masterpiece that will
more than likely win game of the year
depending on how good god of war
ragnarok turns out to be but regardless
of that we'll probably be talking about
elden ring for years to come it is the
greatest success that from software has
ever had and it would be stupid to think
that they aren't working on dlc right
now to expand our understanding of a
world they clearly worked tirelessly on
for all of us to experience i am
frustrated with this game not for a lack
of effort by the developers but more of
a frustration with myself because all i
want to do is make meaningful
entertaining content for you all to
enjoy so that you don't have to go
through these frustrations yourself and
i will get over these frustrations and
the lore videos i'm currently working on
are some of the best i've ever made with
more of an emphasis on the cinematic
visuals of quest lines to better
illustrate the narrative for you guys so
don't for a second think i'm not gonna
keep trying because i love elden ring
too much to be able to give up on it i
just needed to get this out in the air
so i could move on and focus on making
the content i know i'm capable of making
maybe this was better to talk to a
therapist about but i felt the need to
make this video because you are the ones
who support the content your feedback is
how i make all future videos better so i
very much value the input of those that
watch it so thank you all for watching
to the end if you did make it to the end
of this video without leaving an angry
comment on how my frustrations are just
stupid then type bananafoot in the
comments so i know who the real ones are
why bananafoot i don't know i just think
the word is funny if you want to watch
all future lore videos early with no ads
whatsoever you can join my patreon for
as little as three dollars to receive
early access there's also multiple tiers
depending on how much you want to
support thank you to the ones that
already do and thank you again for
watching i will see you all in the next
lore video
take care
[Music]
you